Elon Musk recently made a Twitter poll
asking whether to bring Vine back and
yes won by a landslide but why is he
worried about Tick Tock being Chinese
spyware or is he just being Elon and
trolling everyone but based off these
tweets I think Elon might be serious
this time either way his idea does make
some sense if you consider that Twitter
actually bought Vine for 30 million
dollars back in 2012. even though huge
creators like David dobrik the Paul
Brothers Zach King and King Bach got
popular from Brian it just couldn't
compete with Snapchat and Instagram so
Twitter shut it down just four years
after acquiring it do you want mine to
come back